this Hollywood babble-on with your hosts
Kevin Smith and Ralph Garman sweet [ __ ]
that should not be comes from Bob the
vault he writes in that it's about the
classic Rudolph the red-nosed reindeer
TV special 50 years old this year by the
way no yeah it's been around for 50
years that special still hold there's a
time in our lives where like there was
no cable which means there was no
[ __ ] internet and you lived your
entire life by Christmastime specials
coming on because you could only watch
it once a year yeah you had to map it
out yet have like circled the day in
time so you knew when Charlie Brown was
gonna be on when Rudolph was gonna be on
but now you can [ __ ] open up your
phone and watch a horse [ __ ] a man
that's true and what says Christmas
special more really than mr. hands I
agree yeah Bob's world and Rudolph the
red-nosed reindeer you may remember that
hermie and his friends visit the island
of misfit toys and Bob points out at
very uh this is a two-parter a very
noticeable flaw in this film is that
when they meet the island of misfit toys
one of the toys has a particular problem
let's take a look at this scene okay so
we've got a bird that does not fly he
cannot fly you understand what I'm
saying yeah he's got a major [ __ ]
flaw this bird cannot fly at the end of
the movie Rudolph the red-nosed reindeer
Santa gets all the toys from the island
of misfit toys and gives them to boys
and girls who need them and I think it's
a wonderful ending and there's a very
helpful elf in the back of the sleigh
who is dispersing these toys out of the
back of the sleigh by giving each of the
toy a little parachute type umbrella so
they can jump out of the sleigh and and
just softly be lowered to the ground via
the umbrella except for one of the
[ __ ] toys let's take a look at the
end of this special
[Music]
[Applause]
they never let poor Rudolph join in any
reindeer is a spotty outlet he gets
little parachute there's the [ __ ] yes
just kick his ass overboard I can give
him the boot as Bob rice that
[ __ ] elf looks at him been at the
umbrella shrugs his shoulders and kicks
the I can't fly bird overboard
the elf kills the bird what a [ __ ]
everybody doesn't give the pears you -
[ __ ] you bro
[Music]
you
[Music]